Salut ! Aujourd'hui c'est le jour où je suis le plus à la bourre pour faire la vidéo.
Pourquoi ? Parce que j'ai raté mon train ce matin.
Je suis en date aujourd'hui avec Mister Diablosaur.
-Diablosaur ! -Ouais !
On est du côté de Rochefort dans le 17 et je vais jouer ici!
Et pour la première fois en trois ans de tournée j'ai raté mon train.
Alors en vrai ça va parce que j'étais hyper large sur le temps
Du coup j'ai pris un train 3h et demi après mais le temps que j'avais prévu pour faire la vidéo ici aujourd'hui
était un petit peu compromis mais ça va, je suis encore dans le timing mais c'est juste juste.
Je pense que je vais mettre la vidéo en ligne à 17h vraiment tout pile aujourd'hui.
Et il y a quelques jours je vous avais fait une true story, et je vous avez dit :
si on dépasse les 3000 pouces en l'air, alors j'en ferai une nouvelle.
J'ai regardé ce matin, on est à plus de 6000 déjà !
Alors c'est parti pour une nouvelle true story, je vais vous raconter ce qu'il m'est arrivé hier soir.
Comme quoi c'est hyper frais là.
Hier soir donc, j'allais jouer sur le plateau de la Nouvelle Seine, c'est une péniche théâtre qui est sur la Seine
Et il y a Yacine Belhousse qui a organisé un plateau qui s'appelle "La Première Fois".
Et le but de ce plateau c'est que tu vas sur scène faire quelque chose d'inédit, que tu n'as jamais fait.
Donc moi pour tester un morceau du nouveau spectacle c'était l'idéal.
J'arrive là-bas, je descend en loge, il y a déjà du monde, je dis bonjour à tout le monde,
des gens que je connais, des gens que je ne connais pas dont deux filles et deux mecs qui sont en train
de discuter de tout et de rien et surtout de trucs par rapport à la scène, de comment jouer sur le jeu, etc.
Et je comprends qu'une des jeunes femmes, l'eurasienne en l’occurrence, n'a pas tellement l'habitude de monter
sur scène. Et on se met à discuter tous les deux des petites astuces qu'elle pourrait utiliser
pour se sentir plus à l'aise et être encore plus sincère dans son jeu.
Et je me dis : "je connais cette personne, son visage me dit quelque chose.
Persuadé de l'avoir déjà vu quelque part, qu'on s'est croisé, qu'on a joué ensemble.
C'est sûr, j'ai un souvenir avec elle."
Et impossible de remettre la main dessus. On continue de discuter et puis je ne lui demande pas en fait,
je ne lui pose pas la question de "Où est-ce qu'on s'est vu ? J'ai vraiment l'impression de te connaître."
Parce que j'ai peur qu'elle prenne ça pour de la drague mal placée, donc je ne lui pose pas la question,
et puis il y a tout le monde, et puis je me dit : "Ça va me revenir, on a forcément fait une scène ensemble un jour."
Et il y a Yacine Belhousse qui organisait le plateau et qui présentait qui descend à un moment donné dans les loges et qui me présente un peu plus officiellement
et qui fait : "Ah bah Céline je te présente Fabien. Fabien, Céline. Bon Céline elle est un petit peu flippé parce que
c'est que la deuxième qu'elle monte sur scène. Mais t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer ça va être super !"
Et il s'en va. Donc je me dis : "Non on ne s'est pas rencontré sur scène puisque c'est que la deuxième fois
qu'elle monte sur scène, c'est quand même très très récent." tu vois. Je me dis peut-être qu'elle fait des
vidéos sur Internet  et que je sais pas et que j'ai vu passer ses vidéos. J'étais pas très loin d'ailleurs.
Bref, au final, je n'ose pas lui demander d'où est-ce qu'on se connait. Je me dis, on en parlera après
quand on boira un verra après le spectacle, c'est pas bien grave.
Et le spectacle commence, et tout le monde passe, moi j'étais en dernier donc j'écoutais les autres depuis la loge
Et tous les autres, eux, étaient en salle en train de regarder le spectacle.
Et quelqu'un déboule dans les loges, c'est mon autre pote que vous avez déjà vu aussi sur la chaîne
au tout début de l'année qui s'appelle Marine Baousson. Donc elle descend, elle était au téléphone
elle était en train de répéter, elle aussi c'était un nouveau texte forcément et puis elle me dit : "Qui c'est qui est sur scène ?", je fais "Ah je sais plus... c'est Céline,
fin il y a deux Céline ce soir et j'ai mangé son nom de famille, c'est euh, tu sais la jolie asiatique qui était là."
Et elle me dit : "Ah oui Katsumi !". Et oui c'était Katsumi, c'était vraiment Katsumi.
Alors pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas, Katsumi elle a fait une carrière dans le X, dans la pornographie.
Et ensuite elle a été productrice, et maintenant elle se lance sur scène et elle tente l'aventure du one man show.
Et moi je ne l'avais pas reconnu. Et je suis tellement content de ne pas avoir sorti cette fameuse phrase de :
"Mais on se connait de quelque part, je t'ai déjà vu, tu fais pas des vidéos sur Internet ? Ou un truc comme ça.
devant tout le monde. T'imagines, ça aurait été la honte de ma vie. Donc je suis passé à deux doigts de la honte
de ma vie. Et même cette phrase là elle fait chelou du coup dans le contexte.
Je suis passé pas loin de la honte de ma vie. Je n'ai pas reconnu Katsumi, d'ailleurs son sketch était très drôle,
je l'ai entendu à travers le rideau c'était vraiment chouette.
Mais voilà je me suis marré et depuis hier je me marre là dessus. Du coup ce sera ma true story du jour.
Bon, par contre je me dis que pour la prochaine true story là il faut que je mette la barre
beaucoup beaucoup plus haut. J'avais dit 3000, vous êtes à 6000 ou 7000 là sur la dernière vidéo
Je vais doubler ce que vous avez fait. La prochaine true story, elle sera à 12000. Parce que j'ai plein d'histoires
intéressantes dans ma vie mais j'en ai pas non plus, assez pour en faire une tous les jours en tout cas, je ne crois pas que ça vous intéresserait.
Donc on va dire, à 12000 pouces en l'air je vous ferai une autre true story. Voilà. C'est plus simple.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu. Petit teasing : demain je vous emmène à prendre des décisions comme si vous travaillez pour la Police.
Voilà, c'est un petit indice sur la vidéo de demain.
Passez une excellente journée, si ce n'est pas déjà fait n'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir
puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an du 1er Janvier au 31 Décembre
donc rendez-vous demain à 17h !
Ciao !